yo what are you wearing
they're just shorts you're you can't
just be rockin shorts like that just my
legs why do you look like the rock from
the waist down that's in our office have
some sort of dress code you just decide
to walk up here and act like it's no big
deal that you have the greatest calves
of all time you have soccer tryouts
after work why are you dressed like a
teacher who I would run into at a
blockbuster
why are you dressed like you're about to
give me swim lessons it's hot out is
every day leg day for you why do your
calves look like they could beat me up I
bet your mom had to get a c-section
because of those bad boys if the
apocalypse happened right now I'd eat
you immediately have you never used an
escalator have you ever ridden in a car
are you some sort of experiment between
a boy and a horse you could have gotten
some kind of scholarship for those those
caps are the size of a calf as in baby
cow LeBron James would definitely go
back home to play for those calves do
you normally wear baggy pants and
because of your calves they look like
skinny jeans you look like you could
hike a mountain in six seconds have you
ever sat down tell me why I want to take
a can of Pama just spray your calves
right now I cannot take you seriously
when you're wearing those daisy dukes no
look at that oh my goodness do I have to
send your calves a Christmas card now
hey eyes up here when you run to your
calves chafe I'm sure every girlfriend
you've ever had as motorboated those
puppies did your calves accidentally
sink the Titanic why do you look like
you live on the 67th floor of a hotel
with a broken elevator are you done
yeah sorry I was just
maybe you should warn me next time you
wear shorts to the office
gosh
[Music]